cloud and devops Engineers are closely
interconnected roles that frequently
collaborate in modern software
development and operation although there
is some overlap between the two
positions it has its own distinct areas
of emphasis and responsibilities while
Cloud Engineers Focus mainly on cloud
infrastructures and services devops
engineer focuses more on streamlining
software development and operation
processes collaboration between these
roles is crucial for organization
leveraging Cloud Technologies
effectively while optimizing their
software delivery pipeline top companies
such as Google Microsoft Amazon Netflix
MasterCard American Express and numerous
other actively seek Cloud Engineers
similarly hiring companies like Oracle
Cisco Amazon Google Infosys and Linkedin
are among the top recruiters for devops
engineers hi everyone welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel today's video
will explore the distinguished between
cloud and devops Engineers if if you
aspire to Fast Track Your Cloud engineer
career let me tell you about an amazing
program by simply learn simply learns
postgraduate program in cloud computing
in collaboration with caltex ctme it
gives you the Azure AWS and gcp
expertise this comprehensive
certification course delves into the
depth of cloud computing enabling you to
excel in architectural principles and
acquire the necessary skills to thrive
as a cloud expert isolate your career
trajectory by enrolling In This Cloud
Computing certification program
featuring a comprehensive course
curriculum encompassing crucial Azure
AWS and gcp platform concept the
curriculum also delved into essential
services like AWS Lambda Amazon S3 Azure
app services and many other industry
leading offers so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more details again expertise in top
tools and skills of devops consider
postgraduate program in devops developed
in partnership with caltex ctme which
offers an exceptional opportunity for
professional development this
comprehensive devops training course
equips you with top tools and skills
aligned with Interstate standards our
Innovative blooded learning approach
combines live online devops
certification classes with immensive
interactive Labs enabling you to gain
practical hands-on experience the devops
training course will awaken the
scientific mindset within you as you
learn the art of the formalizing and
documenting development processes
leading to this creation of a
self-documenting system the devops
certification course will also explore
Advanced tools such as puppet and
ansible enabling self-governance and
automated management at scale without
any further delay let's get started with
the topic Cloud engineer versus devops
engineer
engineer specializes in designing
implementing and managing Cloud
infrastructure and services Cloud
Engineers main responsibility is
collaborating with Cloud providers like
Amazon web services Microsoft Azure or
Google Cloud platforms to design
scalable and dependable solution for
application and services
whereas a devops engineer focuses on the
interaction of development and operation
their role is to bridge the gap between
software development team and it
operation to improve collaboration
Automation and efficiency in the
software delivery process Cloud
Engineers typically deeply understand
cloud computing Concepts visualization
networking and security they may work on
tasks such as provisioning and managing
Cloud resources configuring networking
and storage fine-tuning performance and
ensuring High availability and disaster
recovery measures whereas devops
engineer calmly poses a solid software
development and system administration
Foundation leveraging their expertise in
this domain they work to streamline and
automate process such as building and
deploying applications managing
infrastructure as code and implementing
continuous integration and continuous
delivery pipelines some roles and
responsibility of a cloud engineer
include Cloud infrastructure design
Cloud resource provisioning Cloud
Administration security and complaints
Cloud cost optimization and Cloud
migration devops engineer have diverse
roles and responsibility will
encompasses key areas such as continuous
integration and continuous delivery
practices infrastructure as code
implementation configuration management
deployment and release management
monitoring and logging and devops Tool
chain
Cloud Engineers requires a diverse skill
set encompassing various Technical and
non-technical areas such as Linux
database skills programming networking
security and Recovery understanding
visualization and cloud service
providers so here are some of the skills
of cloud engineers
first Cloud platforms Proficiency in
specific Cloud platforms like AWS Azure
or gcp next Cloud infrastructure
designing implementing and managing
Cloud infrastructures then we have
networking and the starting Cloud
networking Concepts including virtual
networks subnets and security groups and
then security and complaints
implementing security measures and
ensuring complaints within the cloud
environment
and then we have automation using
infrastructure as code tools like
terraform or cloud formation to automate
provisioning and management
and then storage conferring and
optimizing cloud storage solutions
and then High availability and Disaster
Recovery designing and implementing
Cloud solutions for high availability
and Disaster Recovery now that you are
aware of cloud engineer skills this
simply lens postgraduate program will
equip you with all the necessary skills
including cloud provider selection
application migration performance
testing Cloud workloads Web Services and
API database management multi-cloud
deployment storage services and many
more and now let's see the skills of
devops Engineers
first we have
CI CD pipelines citicup and managing
continuous integration and deployment
pipelines then infrastructure as code
automating infrastructure provisioning
and configuration using tools like
ansible puppet or chip then
containerization working with
containerization platforms like Docker
and tools like kubernets
and then we have scripting and
programming Proficiency in scripting
languages like python bash or Powershell
as well as programming languages
config management managing and
optimizing the configuration of systems
and applications
and then we have monitoring and logging
implementing monitoring and logging
solutions to ensure applications and
infrastructure performance and finally
collaboration and communication working
effectively with cross-functional teams
and facilating cooperations between
development and operations
now that you know devops engineering
skills this simply learns postgraduate
program will equip you with all the
necessary skills including devops
methodologies continuous integration
continuous delivery deployment
automation Cloud platforms and many more
along with the skills it also covers
tools such as terraform Marvin ansible
Jenkins kubernets Docker and many more
in the upcoming years there will be
higher demand for cloud Engineers due to
the growing usage of devops practices
and cloud computing Technologies some
career opportunities available for cloud
Engineers include Cloud engineer Cloud
architect Cloud consultant Cloud
security engineer Cloud operation
engineer and many more some popular
career opportunities in devops include
devops engineer site reliability
engineer release manager automation
engineer Cloud engineer and many more
according to glasstor the average salary
for a cloud engineer in the United
States is around 100 000 annually in
India it is 6 lakhs per annum the
average salary for devops engineer in
the United States is around 104 000
annually in India it is 7 lakhs per
annum with this we have come to the end
of this Cloud engineer versus devops
engineer if you like this video
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply learn if you need any help
opting for this course please let us
know in the comment section below we
will get back to you as soon as possible
until next time thank you and keep
learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here